oh un statut pour tous parce qu'ils sont
tous essentiels qu'ils soient demandeurs
d'asile étudiants étrangers ou
travailleurs temporaires
ils réclament la régularisation de leur
statut d'immigration
pourquoi est ce qu'il ya des personnes
sans statut qui travaille depuis près de
17 ans ici là dans le noir pour un
minable fallait et au moment d'être
malade fort rapatrier chez eux ou ne
peuvent eux même pas pouvoir aller à
l'hôpital leur statut précaire et les
longs délais du processus d'immigration
limites notamment leur accès aux soins
de santé
je travaille en tant que système de
santé je vois souvent des personnes qui
n'ont pas de papiers qui ont beaucoup
discuté en i avec ça je pense qu'il faut
sept en santé c'était important de
suivre ce processus mais les
gouvernements fédéral prépare un
programme spécial pour régulariser les
anges gardiens de lakovic 19 c
demandeurs d'asile qui travaillent dans
le système de santé comme les préposés
aux bénéficiaires ou à l'entretien
ménager
mais cet accès restreint fera aussi des
laissés-pour-compte selon us
pourquoi est-ce qu'on devrait donner
seulement à une catégorie de personnes
tout le monde a droit à des
régularisations nous ne voulons plus
être discrimination là le but cela je
travaille demandeurs d'asile en attente
depuis 2018
yanji n'a pas cessé de travailler
pendant la pandémie
il craint de ne pas être éligible à ce
nouveau programme spécial nous on a
travaillé dans le social
on a travaillé dans deux compagnies qui
font des
la viande de tout ça donc nous nous
aussi on a vendu que pour qu'on conçoit
dans la dent aujourd'hui sont plus d'une
centaine à marcher dans les rues de
montréal mais le mouvement statut pour
tous prend de l'ampleur depuis quelques
semaines surtout en ontario depuis que
trois travailleurs temporaires étrangers
sont décédées des suites de la commune
19 à toronto où les manifestants se sont
rassemblés devant le bureau du ministre
provincial de l'immigration le visage
des trois migrants décédés placardé une
autre façon de réclamer des changements
minimes si nos stops sur les chaînes une
solution qui soit la même pour tous
demandent les manifestants ici jacques
andré charbonneau radio canada mon frère